hello everybody my name is Carlo
Giacometti and I work in the audio
processing team and I will be talking
about audio synthesis so how to generate
an audio signal and there are so first
of all I want to introduce some basic
concepts and functions that we will use
throughout the whole talk and also the
following one so I will load up three
examples of audio signals
yeah very basic we have one piano sound
which is not playing
it's very feeble can I get more volume
perfect so this is a typical harmonic
sound you could call it I have a
collection of bells in harmonica sound
and then a bit of the dumps that shuddhi
with white these are typical impulsive
sounds that we have so one function that
we will use a lot for visualization that
for sure we have seen already is audio
plot this with this we visualize the
waveform of the signal another very
important function is periodic um with
this we get the power spectrum of the
signal it is the Y scale is in decibels
so we can see all the important dynamic
range of the signal you can see by the
way the first periodogram corresponds to
the harmonic signal you can see there
are some very specific peaks and the
positions of all the peaks are multiple
integers of the position of the first
one this is the kind of definition of a
harmonic one the second one also has a
set of Peaks which are not particularly
the position of which are not
particularly related to each other the
last one looks almost like noise the
last tool that is very important is a
spectrogram it's based on the short time
for that
ferm we have the time on the x-axis and
the frequency on the y-axis so these are
the basic concepts that we'll need now
first of all how do we create an all
your object you probably have seen this
in the introduction talk I just want to
give a quick recap so we can import
either in code or out of color and
existing audio file and this works very
nicely we can create an audio from a
sound object this also works very nicely
we can feed the audio function a table
of values in this case I am creating a
table of a lot of random real values
between minus 1 1 this is white noise
this was fairly loud sorry about that
the other option which is the one that
we will focus on now is use the audio
generator function in this case I am
simply generating a synthoid at the
default frequency of 440 health this is
the most boring sound ever so how can we
make this slightly more interesting so
first of all let's look at how audio
slated works we have a set of basic
waveforms that we can use it's the main
ones that have used in analog audio
synthesis so we have sinusoid triangle
wave saw 2 square etc etc and here you
can see the characteristics of some of
them so soon so it's very boring as one
tick all of the other ones start to
acquire more peaks in the periodic um by
the way is this big enough is can you
all see so okay so we could say other
generator of sawtooth and we are stuck
with a frequency actually no we can
modulate both the frequency and the
phase of the signal in the this is the
important code to generate what's in the
plot here so we can easily move the
frequency and the phase of whatever way
we are generating a side note the
frequency can be negative
give us an inversion of phase now audio
generator is not limited to a harmonic
sound we can also generate noise signals
and we have different kind of different
kind of noises so the most basic one is
the white noise which has a flat
frequency response but we can delve into
all the colored kind of noise where the
frequency response depends on one over F
the frequency to some power we have pink
and brown noise which were the focuses
of low frequency blue noise were the
focuses on high frequency but we can
also have a more general distribution we
can control the Alpha parameter in the
distribution of frequency by using audio
generator of color and specifying this
alpha parameter so we can change fairly
effectively the spectrum of the
resulting signal and this goes all the
way from blue to brown or red however
you want to call it now we have a bit
more freedom as well with our generator
we can have a random one of any of the
random processes existing in Mathematica
as an input here I'm just using a
fractional Gaussian noise still boring
but the fact that we can use any of the
processes already existing in the
language is very exciting another
possible input is a time series Here I
am generating a realization of fashion
Brownian Brownian motion and so the
result is the time series and this can
be fed directly into audio generator so
this gives us freedom to throw big time
series directly into all your objects so
here I have a query the wind speed data
object I will not run it right now
because I don't think I have an internet
connection at the moment but I did
evaluate this previously so it's just
the values of this time series scaled to
fit a proper time range and they are
simply used as values for our audiences
and more exciting stuff that was already
possible with play and sample sound
function with an input a pure function
and generate an audio signal from that
okay so these are we have seen noises
basic sliders these are simple signals
how can we make them more interesting
one classic technique is subtractive
synthesis the whole idea is to start
with a complex waveform and pass it
through filters to modify the spectral
content in the old days of analog and
electronics this was achieved by big
things modular synthesizers like this
thing so you had an oscillator module
and a filter module it would take a
cable and plug the cable in this later
plug it in the filter and so then you
get your resulting signal in Mathematica
it seems to be fairly easier than that
with this single line of code I generate
a sawtooth and filter it with a low-pass
filter and here we can see what effect a
low-pass filter has on a sawtooth wave
you can see both the spectrum and the
wave from changing same thing with a
high specific like shadow is saying we
haven't a big suite of signal processing
and we have a big collection of analog
filter models and we can simply use
those we just need to take care of
transforming them to discrete time
models but then we can use any of those
with recurrence filter that directly on
an audio object
[Music]
so this is a way of creating more
complex spectra as you can see and more
more complex way from then basically
laters now there is kind of the opposite
approach instead of having a complex
waveform and filtering it we can just
add harmonic components made up by very
simple sinusoids so here I just generate
a table of frequency and they are all
harmonic frequencies the fundamental
frequency is 200 and I just generate a
random vector of a random list of
amplitudes I can just generate sinusoids
with the specified frequencies and the
specified amplitudes and just take the
mean of those and I get away from with a
complex spectrum now we are not limited
of course to harmonic 3/2 harmonic
signals now if instead of a list of of
harmonic frequencies I just give a
random list of frequencies the result is
much more unpredictable more similar to
sounds that are characteristics of bells
and this kind of in harmonic objects
another other techniques one that shadi
showed quickly is amplitude modulation I
have two signals and one modulates the
amplitude of the other so here I have a
triangle wave and a sinusoid and the
multiplication this is the fantastic
thing about Audion the intervals of
language I just need to do a
multiplication in the Sun and I get an
int well and it depends on taste but
this is definitely a more complex result
and you can look at the spectrum we have
the carrier that has its harmonic
frequencies and these are odd harmonics
the modulator with is a simple
simulation as a single peak and there
amplitude modulation process for each
peak of the courier creates a couple of
sideburns and the distance between the
main frequency and the sideburns
corresponds to the frequency of the
modulating signal same kind of
components but very different result is
frequency modulation we still have a
carrier and moderator but now the
modulator is controlling the frequency
not the amplitude of the carrier so to
achieve this we have animation how we
are trying to have as many as the time
varying arguments as possible so take
this for example here I have the model
specification and the second argument in
this list is supposed to be the
frequency specification now this
frequency specification is at all
effects and all the objects I can
evaluate this in place and you can see
this is now my frequency specification
for this audio generator object and it's
a sinusoid slowly varying this will give
us a very slow vibrato effect now okay
this is not overly interesting but the
frequency of this modulating signal now
can be raised to the audio range and
this starts to produce much more complex
in harmonics and this is the basic
algorithm on which the famous Yamaha dx7
synthesizer is built on essentially and
so we have two parameters to control to
shape the spectrum of our signal we can
change the modulation frequency and we
can change the modulation index that
tells us how much of this modulation is
happening and you can see I am varying
the modulation index and the bigger it
is the more side bands appear I can
change the modulation frequency and this
instead affects the locations of the
assignments now
it is fairly difficult to think of a
sound and figuring out how to produce it
with frequency modulation the result is
I would know it is not unpredictable but
it's very difficult to visualize one
easy way to start I guess is if the
ratio between the carrier frequency and
the moderating frequency is an integer
make sure we get a harmonic sound here
we have several examples you can see
these are all harmonic spectrum just
play a sense harmonic if instead we use
something that's not that's irrational
like pi square root of 2 of the golden
ratio we get highly in harmonic spectrum
one of the many and noisy examples now I
showed at the beginning of this slide
how I can have a time varying argument
here but there's nothing stopping me for
putting in this nested modulator another
modulator so I could have nested
modulations here with this example I
have a sim side which is modulated by a
slowly varying sinusoidal signal so this
gets us a more dynamic sound that's
evolving with time until now we always
had static sounds they were not changing
nothing interesting was happening this
way we can add some life to it well some
variation to it
and you can see what's happening by
visualising on a Spectre young whenever
that log computer here yeah okay so
another strategy that's kind of unique
to Mathematica
well the generation of this is unique in
Mathematica as a convenient thing is to
let's say we choose a physical system in
this case they chose a vibrating damped
string in Mathematica we can easily
define a system a differential equation
of a system of differential equations
and solve them so this is what this code
does this will take a bit of time
because in the solution there will be
many oscillations given the time scale
and the selected frequency so it will
take a bit of time but then what can we
do apart from plotting the result of
curve is evaluating this function this
interpolating function and just feeding
the data into an audio object so
eventually when this will
here we are so in this case the
exposition a the X parameter that I have
in these manipulates is the positions at
which I am sensing the vibration if any
of you plays electric guitar this is
equivalent the position of a pickup
essentially and the sound is not
dramatically different the model is very
simple it's just a damped string so not
particularly exciting but we do get a
sound and we are able to change the
spectral content by moving essentially
the sensing position no here we have
some less scientific but more fun
examples let's say so here I am just
controlling the frequency of my sinews
oscillator which is in the South are
burning I am grabbing the digits of pi
and I am converting them in base 24 and
I'm just controlling the frequency of
the oscillator with these numbers the
sequin is fairly predictable if we want
something more predictable that shows
some patterns we can I use here a
rational number here we go we have a
constant matter so we can play with this
kind of sonification
of data let's say another interesting
example this is a function that use
exclusively bit-wise operations and so
looking at it there is nothing special
or interesting about this turns out that
this kind of construct can produce very
complex structures
[Music]
another this is a silly example but it's
definitely something one can do so here
I grab the text from the nad in Latin
and I can just firm the characters into
numbers and play those as expected very
much white noise so another fun example
let's see if I the intimate helps me
here I can go up some financial data
actually let me I have the data here let
me instead of connecting to the internet
and who knows what happens this should
work fairly nicely
okay and Here I am just controlling the
frequencies of a vector of sinusoidal
oscillators with these audio data so I
can certify some kind of market data in
this case and I can control the volume
of the relative the relative intensity
for the various companies in this case
we are listening the stock price of
Microsoft but we could add Apple general
tonics and we can listen them together
so we can have a sense devolution of the
stock prices this is another interesting
experiment so I showed you many spectral
guns it is an image and we can
manipulate it shadi showed some
transformations but the problem here
that I want to show is it slightly
difference so here we have a simple
image what if this image was the
spectral gun of a sound how would that
sound how could we generate a sound that
produces this bacterium so let's grab
some images this code is not all very
interesting but essentially does that
the whole idea is I generate a matrix of
complex values and I control the
amplitudes of those with the values in
the image and I do the inverse
transformation so let's compute that for
the images we have let's display them
here we go so we have the image and the
corresponding sound I will play a couple
of them randomly and as its activation
and all of those have
very different characteristics from each
other now let's check that I didn't
promise something that I didn't live it
was shocked that I actually got the same
image that I shown here let's see if
this worked same monkey I think it
worked ok I think this is it for
synthesis